So I want to start by showing you two paragraphs. Here's the first one. They're
all so different Boylan talking about the shape of my foot. He noticed once
even before he was introduced. When I was in the DBC with Poldy laughing and
trying to listen, I was waggling, my foot. We both order two teas and plain
bread, and butter and I saw him looking with his two old maids of sisters, when
I stood up and asked the girl, where it was, what do I care with it dropping
out of me and that black closed breeches he made me buy, takes you half an hour
to let down, wetting all myself, always, with some brand new fad every other
week. Here's the second one. This creation in which we live, began with the
Dominant Nature as an Identification Body. With a completed evolutionary Strong
Material creation in a Major Body Resistance Force. And is fulfilling the
Nature Identification in a Like Weaker Material Identification creation in
which two major bodies have already fulfilled radio body balances, and
embodying. A third material identification embodiment of both. So, what do you
think about these two paragraphs? Is either one creative, or both, or are
neither? Check whichever one you feel is creative.